Musik Ja, Herr Tietze, schön, dass Sie heute gekommen sind. Sie sind ja der Vertreter des Das Podcast, UFO wie es mit den neuen Geldern aussieht, mit der Finanzierung. Sie hatten ja letztes Jahr ein, ich sag mal, ein durchwachsenes Jahr, wo wir uns bestimmt noch auf viele Verbesserungen freuen dürfen, nehme ich mal an. Oder wie sehen Sie das? Ja, der Grund war ja letztes Jahr, es lief ja von den Einnahmen her ganz gut, auch danke nochmal, dass wir am Anfang von Ihnen das Startkapital bekommen haben. Genau. Ja, und dann hat irgendwie mein Kollege, ich will nicht sagen, sich die Taschenfolge machen mit dem Geld. Ja. Aber er hat einfach dann auch sich plötzlich den Fernseher damit finanziert und solche Sachen. Das ist der Valentin, genau. Florentin. Wie bitte? Florentin. Florentin. Den wollten wir eigentlich auch heute einladen, aber allerdings haben wir ihn jetzt nicht telefonisch erreichen können. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo der ist. Das ist ja ein großes Problem. Ja. Ich meine, das letzte Mal hat er mich angerufen, da war ja, weiß ich nicht, Honolulu oder sowas hat er gesagt. Er hat das natürlich genuschelt, wie er immer spricht, man versteht ihn ja nicht so gut mehr, durch die neuen Lippen, die er hat. Wahrscheinlich auch sehr oft unterbrochen, nehme ich an. Ich habe ihn sehr oft unterbrochen, aber er hat auch diese neuen Lippen, die er jetzt hat. Also er hat sich glaube ich auch irgendwie das aufspritzen lassen so ein bisschen. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, ihn da zu verstehen. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, Sie haben mich jetzt eingeladen, weil Sie das Geld. Ja, also wir müssen überlegen, wie wir das mit der Finanzierung machen 2016, weil ich sag mal so, der Rückhalt in der Firma hat ein bisschen zurückgegangen tatsächlich, was ihr Projekt angeht, weil sie haben uns ja Anfang des Jahres Zahlen versprochen an Hörern und an positiven Kommentaren da. Sie erinnern sich da bestimmt an die Gespräche, die wir geführt haben, betreffend Stefan Schwiers. Und jetzt habe ich mir letztens nochmal die Zahlen angeguckt und da ist ja noch viel Platz. Weil wir die nicht ausgefüllt haben. Wir haben manche ausgefüllt. Wir dachten doch erst, es wäre ein Sudoku, das Formular, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wir dachten da erst, was fragen wir da ein und dann am Ende haben wir noch nicht mehr zu Ende ausgefüllt, da war es auch etwas sehr schwieriges Sudoku oder es war kein Sudoku. Das hat man sich ja oft, oder? Ist es ein schwieriges Sudoku oder ist es gar kein Sudoku?
Ich würde mal ganz kurz auf ein paar konkreter eingehen an der Sache. Sie haben ja im Juni
haben Sie eine Villa gekauft in Amerika für 200 Dollar, sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, das ist sozusagen, das war ein Gewinnspiel, wo wir daran teilgenommen haben. Und da haben
wir uns für 200 Dollar mitgemacht. Haben Sie das Horst denn gewonnen? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Rückblickend hat Florentin aber seitdem sich komisch benommen. Aber Sie haben schon... Ich glaube, er hat das gewonnen und ist dann ab und zu mal dahin. Ja. Er war die Wochenenden auch nicht mehr da und konnte plötzlich auch nicht mehr so oft aufnehmen. Na gut, 200 Euro, Lirum Larum. Allerdings im August haben sich hier mehrere 24 Tickets gebucht nach Basel. Wie kam es dazu? 24? Ja, über einen Zeitraum von zwei Wochen haben sie immer wieder Tickets gebucht und dann gekündigt und wieder gebucht. Ja, da wollten wir erst hinfahren, dann hat es immer nicht geklappt und dann dachten wir, wir haben meistens vergessen, als wir uns dann entschieden, doch wiederzufahren, dass wir schon Tickets haben. Oktober eine Reise nach Aachen tatsächlich mit anschliessender Behandlung wegen Haarallergie. Daran erinnere ich mich nicht mehr. Das kann aber auch ein Nebeneffekt der Allergie sein. Filmriss. Allerdings, Sie haben da auch viele Formulare relativ kryptisch ausgefüllt, wie ich das gerade hier vormittigen habe. Und dann haben wir nochmal eine Reise nach Hamburg. Ist das ein Kreuzverhör hier eigentlich? Wie gesagt, es geht um die finanzielle Zukunft Ihres Projekts. Herr Tizze. Tizze. Ja. Eine Reise nach Hamburg haben wir da noch stehen, Ende November? Ich dachte, Flatter wäre eigentlich ein ganz anderes Programm. Ich dachte, man kann ja freiwillig spenden, aber ich wusste nicht, dass sie uns komplett finanzieren mittlerweile. Ja, wir haben ihnen Anfang des Jahres einen Kredit von 10.000 Euro gegeben. 10.000 Euro. Aber der wäre für drei Jahre gedacht, ne? Also da haben sie jetzt noch was übrig. Okay. Man, ja, okay, ja, ja. Herr Titzel, ich muss Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen, Sie müssen sich ein bisschen zusammenreissen finanziell. Sie müssen versuchen, dass Geld reinkommt, Ihre T-Shirts verkaufen sich, meint, sehe ich das richtig, dass Sie mit, ich sehe hier einen negativen Betrag bei Einkommen, dass Sie die T-Shirts, wie Sie kaufen T-Shirts, Sie kaufen Ihre eigenen T-Shirts, oder? Das Ding ist, das das ergibt jetzt für mich überhaupt keine Sitzung. Nee, nee, ganz kurz, Herr, wie war Ihr Name, Herr, wie war Ihr Name nochmal? Egal, das Ding bei, wir haben was über das Breadshirt gemacht. Das ist ein Unternehmen, da kann man dann Dinge verkaufen, mit einem eigenen Logo. Sehr gut, klingt nach einem guten Konzept. Ja, und da musste man dann halt auch, da muss man dann für das Design, was man erstellt hat, eigentlich einen Betrag angeben. Ja, perfekt, dann können Sie ja so Einnahmen generieren, mit denen Sie dann langfristig den Kredit unterstützen und abbezahlen können. Ja, das Problem ist, wir haben das falsch verstanden. Wir zahlen quasi drauf, wenn man unser Design kauft. Sie zahlen drauf, wenn Leute ihre Designs kaufen. Müssen Sie etwas zahlen. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch Werbung. Die Leute machen ja Werbung. Ah, Moment, Entschuldigung, jetzt ziehe ich hier ganz kurz. Kam gerade eine Überweisung rein. 32.000 Euro von Busta. Busta? Ne, das ist halt eine spanische Firma zu sein. Busta, Comprendo, prego, Stefano Tizioso. Aha.
Das ist mein Urgrossonkel.
Aha.
Mein spanischer Urgrossonkel, der mir, ähm, ach, das ist, äh, ich hab geerbt, ich hab Spanien geerbt.
Ja, wunderbar.
Da brauchst du aber gar nicht weiter auf eingehen.
Dann sehe ich da eigentlich keinen Grund mehr, sie nicht weiter im Team begrüssen zu dürfen, Herr...
Nein, Tize.
Tize.
Tize war der Name.
Und... Wie, wie, wie, wie waren Sie noch, wie hießen Sie noch mal? Wie bitte? Wie hießen Sie noch mal? Ich bin Herr Tietze. Tietze war der Name. Wie hießen Sie nochmal? Wie hießen Sie nochmal? Ich bin Herr Kreisseln. Kose, Klusel, Klusa, Klus, wie der Herr Baum. Ja, dann treffen wir uns, würde mich mal freuen, auch Ihren Lebensgefährten, Ihren Kollegen, Ihren Lebensgefährten kennenzulernen. Und dann würde ich sagen, auf ein frohes neues Jahr 2016. Viel Spaß, und ich würde sagen, Sie bleiben dran. Nein, am Ende sagen Sie immer, und jetzt heben wir ab. Ah, was? Das sagen wir immer, ja. Also, dann sage ich jetzt liebe Grüße und wir heben ab. Und dann? Dann ist meistens auch die Auge vorbei. Aber da kommt noch noch ... Haben Sie es schon mal reingehört eigentlich? Nee. Nee? Da kommt nichts. Machen wir immer. Machen Sie das doch mal. Nee, machen Sie das doch mal. Machen Sie doch mal. Sagen wir mal, wir heben jetzt ab. Machen wir immer. Na, danke. Wunderbar, hat mich sehr gefreut. Dankeschön. Wunderbar. Dankeschön für die Finanzierung. Ja, grüße. Wiedersehen. Jetzt mal Flo und die Anrufenden das Sagen. Oh, mein Handy klingelt. Töne. Warte, wo ist es denn nochmal? Oh, Entschuldigung. Hier irgendwo muss es sein. Will, guten Tag. Hi, Florentin, ich bin Stefan. Sorry, dass ich mit der anonymen... Entschuldigung, ich höre es gerade nicht richtig. Stefan ist hier, Tietze, hallo. Äh, wegen der Vermietung? Nein, wir machen den Podcast zusammen. Ich musste mit der anonymen Nummer anrufen, weil du sonst nicht reingehst. Ach Stefan, Stefan Natzel. Tietze. Mensch, dass es den noch gibt. Tietze. Da studierst du noch, du alter Ratte, oder was? Tietze, vom Ufo, vom Ufo halt. Vom Ufo, nicht Natzel, Tietze, vom Ufo, Tietze. Tietze, ahaha, Tietze, ah geil, das ist ja geil. Ja, ich muss da mit anonymen, sorry. Alles klar, ich muss da leider auch los. Aber ganz kurz, es ist relativ wichtig, mit der Finanzierung bis 2016, da habe ich mit Herrn Klusel gesprochen, Klusa. Ja, ja. Das ist so, dass alles läuft, alles. Wir sind Neo, Neo, das haben wir mal gemacht. Genau, das haben wir immer so mal gelacht.
Okay, ähm, also, es ist mal da. Wie machen wir das eigentlich bis 2016?
Wie bitte?
Wollen wir da nochmal aufnehmen, hast du noch Lust eigentlich so richtig oder läuft es nicht mehr so?
Klar habe ich Lust, immer.
Wo bist du denn gerade?
Warum bist du gerade nicht...
Oh, ist gerade ganz schlecht, ich bin gerade auf dem Flughafen und es ist gerade ein bisschen schwierig gerade.
Aber klar, machen wir nächste Woche.
Oder?
Donnerstag hat man immer gesagt. Ja, wir hatten auch Montag schon mal gesagt, aber da hast machen wir nächste Woche, oder? Donnerstag hatten wir immer gesagt.
Wir hatten auch Montag schon mal gesagt, aber da hast du dann
mich sitzen lassen leider.
Ah, sorry, das tut mir leid, das ist wegen der Zeitumstellung,
aber ich dachte, du meinst Donnerstag.
Donnerstag ist ganz schlecht,
machen wir nächste Woche, oder? Machen wir einfach nächste Woche.
Ja, das wäre dann ganz gut eigentlich,
weil wir langsam wieder anfangen.
Ja, alles klar.
Achtung, wir! Heben ab. Wie hast du immer gemacht? Mach nochmal. Also, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche. Und wir heben ab. Geil, Tütze. Tschüss. So ein Arschloch, ey. Na, warte mal, da muss ich mal ganz kurz meinen Agenten anrufen.
Du, du, du, was ist das denn? Funky Lord 83. Duuut!
Waren gehen.
Duuut!
Hallo?
Martin?
Wer ist denn da?
Martin, hallo, Florentin hier. Hallo?
Martin?
Wer ist denn da?
Martin, hallo, Florentin hier.
Ach, Florentin, hi, Flo, wie geht's dir denn? Hi, alles klar bei dir da drüben, oder? Oggi, Oggi, Oggi!
Was gibt's denn?
Du altes Sau, wenn du...
Geht's dir noch, wie geht's Martina?
Martina geht's super.
Ich sag mal, die Kinder, die sind jetzt drüben, ne?
Ja.
Aber ich mein, was willst du machen?
Ist das geil. Geht's dir noch, wie geht's Martina? Martina geht's super, ich sag mal, die Kinder, die sind jetzt drüben, ne?
Ja.
Aber ich mein, was willst du machen?
Ist das geil.
Aber ist doch alles, ich sag ja immer, was muss, das muss.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und ich mein, solange das Geld stimmt, ist es ja alles okay.
Martina und Martin, oder? Das ist immer noch, ich glaub's nicht.
Ich find's auch lustig.
Ich mein, als hätte sich irgendein Geschichtenerzähler, das ist ganz schlecht einfach ausgedacht.
Gerade eben.
Unkreativer Typ, gerade eben ausgedacht.
Du, mich hat der Stefan Natzel gerade nochmal angerufen, der wollte sich nochmal melden, weil wir ein neues Podcastprojekt starten wollten, meinte er.
Ja.
Und ich dachte...
Ist ein nefiger Typ.
Ist ein mega nefiger Typ.
Ich dachte, dass wir...
Dann kann man kurz nochmal zusammensetzen.
Ich habe eigentlich gesagt, dass du es nicht mehr hättest, dass du den Katastthema abbrechen solltest.
Ja, aber dass wir uns da vielleicht nochmal kurz wegen den Konzepten zusammenlegen, weil irgendwie das, keine Ahnung, irgendwie ein paar neue Ideen, irgendwie ein bisschen was frischen Wind oder so, dass wir irgendwie nicht immer den gleichen Scheiss machen, sondern einfach ein bisschen was überlegen. Ihr macht mal eine Ranking-Show oder sowas. Top 8 einfach. Ja, gibt's auch schon, Top 10 gibt's schon so viele, Top 20. Ja, aber fällt uns nicht noch irgendwas ein. Top 80 oder sowas, wo ihr so ein bisschen was mit füllen könnt und dann haut ihr da ein paar so Top-Celebrities oder sowas. Wir machen auf gar keinen Fall Hörspiele. Nie wieder mache ich Hörspiele, auf gar keinen Fall. Das war furchtbar. Das war das Dümmste, was wir überhaupt je machen könnten. Wir machen keine Live-Events mehr, das war ein Riesenreinfall damals in Basel. Das war niemand da. Weil woher sollen wir wissen, dass Basel nicht Barcelona ist und dass unsere Gag-Autoren uns im wichtigsten Moment zurückla... Warte, ich schreibe mir ganz kurz auf, warte, das ist ganz geil, den haue ich heute noch in die Sendung. Wir nehmen ja später auf, ne, also am Donnerstag. Ja, mach dir mal, Jungs. Gut. Warum hast du noch mal, ich meine, wir sind alle Schulkameraden, warum hast du mich mal gefragt, ob ich denn Agent sein will? Ich meine, ich bin beruflich Bankkaufmann, ich weiss nicht genau, warum du mich das anrufst.
Ich meine, das ist ganz nett, weil so.
Ich gebe deine Nummer immer weiter, ich gebe deine Nummer weiter. Paul, letztens habe ich deine Nummer gegeben.
Hat er die anrufen?
Ich ruf ganz letztendlich mal Menschen an.
Ja, Betty! Betty, dachte ich, die wäre was für dich.
Ja, kannst du das bitte leiden lassen einfach?
Hallo, Betty!
Ja, Martina? Sorry?
Ja, aber hast du ja Betty gesehen, du?
Sie war zwölf.
Ja, und? Aber hast du den Schulrand gesehen?
Sie sah aus wie vierzehn, okay.
Verstehst du? Die Schultüten gesehen?
Martin! Martin! Martin! Oder?
Ich muss jetzt das einmal auflegen.
Du altes Sogemächt!
Mach's gut, ne? Mach dir doch einmal...
Du bist der Geilze!
Oh, warte, wem ab!
Wem ab!
Ja, sauer!
Mach's gut, ciao!
Ciao! Ja, sauer. Mach's gut, ciao. Ciao. Schönen guten Abend, herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge, Folge 51, wir freuen uns, jetzt berüsten zu dürfen, zur Folge 51 des Hochgelobten, von der Kritik gelobten, von Fans erwarten. Ich habe sogar eine Kritik da, ich habe eine Kritik da. Podcast, Kultpodcast, das Podcast UFO mit Florentin Will und Stefan Thietze. Ich habe eine Kritik da. Eine abscheuliche Demonstration von schlecht gespieltem und völlig übertriebenem Enthusiasmus, für die man sich in den Boden schämen kann. Der Unsympathfaktor bei Florentin war auch jenseits von Gut und Böse. Wie manche das als Humor empfinden können und feiern, ist wirklich absurd. Das war die Kritik zur letzten Folge. Vielen Dank nochmal dafür. Nee, das war die Kritik zu deinem Auftreten beim Chat-Duell, glaube ich. Völlig richtig, jetzt bin ich kurz zueinander gekommen tatsächlich. Ja, ich war in Hamburg richtig... Man kommt vor schlechten Kritiken ganz durcheinander. Man weiß gar nicht mehr, wo wir die einordnen sollen. Auch privat krieg ich sehr oft... War das jetzt eigentlich, also wir erinnern uns alle, wenn nicht Folge 12 nochmal nachhören, an das grosse Pokémon-Desaster von Florentin. Und er schafft es, das immer nochmal zu toppen bei den Rocket Beans. Mit jedem Aufritt kriegt das nochmal ein neues Skandalchen. Du bist ja so ein Skandalnudel bisher. Aber war das jetzt schlimmer als Pokémon oder war das nicht so schlimm? Ich würde sagen, es war tatsächlich schlimmer, weil das Format vergebender war. Bei Pokémon kann man nur verlieren. Du gehst da rein und du scheiterst eigentlich in dem Moment, in dem du durch die Tür gehst. Und bei Chat-Duell hast du alle Möglichkeiten der Welt und scheiterst da. So dass wenn du ein anspruchsvolles Instrument spielst, Teremin, da kannst du eigentlich nur scheitern, siehst dabei aber noch gut aus. Wohingegen wenn du ein einfaches Instrument spielst, wie zum Beispiel Klavier, ja, okay, von mir aus Klavier, dann wird es schwierig, weil alle denken, ja gut, jawohl, eigentlich ist Klavier ja nur eine sehr aufwendige Gitarre im Grunde, oder? Es ist vor allem eine Gitarre, also bei einer Gitarre musst du ja um einen Ton zu erzeugen, ja schon mal ein bisschen was leisten, du musst richtig greifen, du musst richtig einschlagen und so weiter, du musst die Gitarre richtig rumhalten. Und beim Klavier drückst du auf den Knopf. Und beim Klavier drückst du auf den Knopf und es kommt dann ein Ton raus, der perfekt ist. Lame. Mega lame eigentlich. Eigentlich total lame. Deswegen fangen ja mehr Leute an, Klavier zu spielen, als Einschließinstrument, also zum Beispiel sich einer Gitarre zu widmen. Wohingegen Teremin ist das einfachste. Du hältst einfach deine Hand random vor dich und im Idealfall kommt ein Cis raus. Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass die Leute nicht wissen, was ein Theramin ist, tatsächlich. Ach, aber die googeln das ja jetzt. Aber du hast ja als Jugendlicher immer Klavier gespielt und hast dann immer am Lagerfeuer schön das Klavier rausgeholt. Die Bretter gelegt in den Garten, nochmal aus dem Wohnzimmer und dann ein bisschen geschoben. Ja, da war das Lager meistens schon vorbei, als sie das Klavier aufgebaut hatte. Ja, tatsächlich. Oder immer sagen, könnt ihr mal kurz leise sein, ich spiele schon mal Chopin, aber ihr müsst leise sein.
Dann einfach aus dem Wohnzimmer gehofft, dass
Bettina, die süße Bettina aus der Parallelklasse
über das Dosentelefon, das sie noch hört.
Leider nicht.
Das ist kein Bullshit, oder?
Nö.
Aber die Idee ist doch, dass
die Schnur gespannt ist, so dass
die Vibrationen von dem Dosenboden
des Senders korrespondieren mit dem Dosenboden des Empfängers. Das funktioniert schon, oder? Ich glaube, es hat noch nie jemand das Wort korrespondieren im Zuge eines Dosentelefons in Verbindung gebracht. Weil wenn man in Comics Dosentelefone sieht, dann hängt die Schnur oft durch, was ja Quatsch ist, weil dann fährst du den Effekt ja nicht mehr. Der Mann aber nicht nämlich auch. Aber ich glaube, das ist schon so weit ist man mittlerweile mit der Entwicklung von Dosentelefonen, dass theoretisch auch eine durchhängige Schnur auch funktionieren würde. Bin ich der Meinung. Immer noch einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsgags bei den Simpsons, wie die CIA dieses Dosentelefon ankappt und da so ein Kabel drüberlegt und die so angezapft hat. Mega lustig, kann ich sehr drüber lachen. Also, wo wir jetzt gerade schon beim Thema Physik sind.
Wir haben viele Fragen bekommen, viele Mails bekommen,
viele Kommentare bekommen. Stefan,
Florentin, ihr habt ja letzte Woche eine Rubrik gestartet.
Florentin und Stefan erklären die Welt.
Und einiges passiert in der Welt der Physik.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast.
Ich kann mal kurz den Jingle ab.
Wir sind Florentin und Stefan, die Physikgegle. .de. .de. .org. Unendliche Weiten. Unendliche Möglichkeiten. Unendliche Weiten. Unendlich viele Fragen und nur eine Antwort. Manchmal auch keine. Stefan und Florentin. Tietze und Will sind Florentin. Physik. Und zwar geht es heute um das heisse Thema, wahrscheinlich konntet ihr euch kaum retten, vor diesem Thema in der letzten Woche, Gravitationswellen. Gravitationswellen! Haben wir das nicht schon erklärt? Gravitationswellen heisst das Thema der Stunde. Habe ich das nicht schon erklärt? Ausufernd, drei, vier Stunden lang? Ja, aber ich glaube, die Folge haben wir gelöscht. Die ist, glaube ich, untergegangen. Ganz gut, letzte Woche fanden wir wieder nicht statt. Wobei, man ja mal überlegen. Sorry, wollte ich nur sagen. Ich möchte nochmal einen zweiten Turn aufmachen. Was heißt denn pro Woche, wenn du jetzt immer mittwochs aufnimmst, zu einem zwanzig, zu einem zwanzig, zu einem zwanzig, zu einem zwanzig, zu einem zwanzig, zu einem zwanzig, aber wenn du jetzt immer montags aufnimmst und dann irgendwann immer donnerstags aufnimmst, dann hast du ja einmal die Lücke. Eine Woche, wo nichts stattfindet, ja. Und wenn du nur einmal pro Woche stattfindest, also Donnerstag, dann in der nächsten Woche am Dienstag, dann sagen, ja, wir haben ja die Woche aufgenommen, also können wir nächste Woche am Donnerstag, dann verlierst du ja auch Zeit. Lass mich anders ausdrücken. Früher gab es den Simpsons-Comic und der kam immer raus am Donnerstag und dann hieß es immer, ja, wenn du Abonnent wirst, dann kriegst du den schon am Mittwoch. Und dann dachte ich mir, eigentlich ist das überhaupt keine Zeitersparnis, weil du immer eine Woche warten musst. Du hast nur ein einziges Mal eine Zeitersparnis von einem Tag, aber dann musst du immer wieder genau eine Woche auf die nächste Ausgabe warten. Aber da ist ja eher ein netter Gedanke, aber da ist ja eher der Gedanke, dass du vor deinen Freunden, die beiden besten Gags, die du schon mit dem Textmarker markiert hast, um die dann nochmal in der Schule zu rezitieren, irgendwie in der letzten Reihe. Das ist ja, glaube ich, das Ding, dass du halt vor deinen Freunden das weißt. Aber du hast recht. Ich hatte nie Freunde, deswegen kann ich das nicht einschätzen, tatsächlich. Deswegen hast du das Thema nicht verstanden, genau. Aber ziemlich clever eigentlich gemacht von denen. Hat mir auch schon aufgefallen, ich glaube, das ist sehr deutlich in der Relativitätstheorie erklärt, wie man Podcasts wann aufnehmen sollte, damit man quasi keine Zeit verliert, keine Zeit, die Letation entsteht. Oder wie man sich ein bisschen Zeit erschleichen kann tatsächlich. Zurück zu Gravitationswellen, wir haben ja angesprochen, wir haben uns ja mal kurz angeguckt, wie das ist mit der Gravitationsflut und der Gravitationsebbe und momentan befinden wir uns in der Gravitationsflut. Das heißt, wir werden alle immer schwerer mit der Zeit, also wir werden immer schwerer, schwerer, schwerer. Bei manchen sieht man es auch. Das war vielleicht ein bisschen zu spitz gerade. Müssen wir das rausschneiden? Zu keck. Ich glaube, das war zu sch... Wir fragen mal kurz die Schnittpolizei. Ganz kurz, Andi? Schnittpolizei. Ja, oder Andi,
je nachdem, wenn ich es zuerst sage,
kannst du nicht mehr noch eine andere Idee hinterher.
Also auch unsere Hörspiel ist ein bisschen inkohärent
immer, weil wir uns immer wieder sprechen.
Inkohärent. Oh, Herr Professor
Doktor Dietzer. Ich habe die besseren
Wörter in diesem Podcast.
Ich glaube, die meisten
sagen, Florentin ist zwar nett, aber Stefan hat
die besseren Wörter. Hat mehr Wörter und die besseren Wörter. Dafür habe ich die besseren Worte. Okay. Also wir befinden uns gerade auf einer Gravitationsflut. Das heißt, wir werden immer schwerer und schwerer bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, denn der Mond beeinflusst ja die Gezeiten. Und wenn der Mond sich um einmal um die Erde gedreht hat und um sich selbst dreht der Mond, nee der Mond dreht sich nicht, der Mond dreht sich aber um die Sonne.
Wenn er einmal rum ist, dann kommt die Gravitationsebbe und alle werden wieder leichter. Das heisst, wir müssen gar nicht abnehmen, sondern können einfach warten, bis wir alle wieder leichter werden. Deswegen ist es ja so lustig, weil der Mond zeigt immer nur eine Seite. Und deswegen wollen Menschen ja, waren Menschen auch schon hinter dem Mond und fanden das so toll, weil zum ersten Mal die andere Seite des Mondes, die dunkle Seite der Erde abgewandt. Da stand dann die Suck oder sowas drauf. Da stand dann genau, Kick Me. Das hat niemand geglaubt. Ab dem jetzt so ein Ding draufgeklebt. Suck my ass. Das wäre was für Rute, oder? Das wäre was für Rute. Können wir noch mal eine kurze Hausaufgabe an Ruth rausgeben?
Dass der Mond hinten mal gucken soll, ob er nicht ein Kick-Me-Schild hat oder so? Genau, dass die ersten Astronauten hinter den Mond fliegen und dann sind dann den You Stink oder sowas. Klebt dann da hinten drauf. Ruthi, wenn du das hörst, wir können so überprüfen, ob unsere Gäste überhaupt noch unseren Podcast hören, indem wir immer kleine Aufgaben und Hausaufgaben verteilen. Und jetzt haben wir einen Ruthie, Ralpeha Ruthie, und die Aufgabe verteilt, diesen kleinen,
diese kleine, illustrer Einfall von mir, dann von Stefan geklaut, umzusetzen. Mit unseren beiden Namen vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, dass man ein paar Follower kriegt bei Twitter. Das wäre ganz gut, tatsächlich. Wir haben Post bekommen von Ralf, wir haben zwei DVDs bekommen. Ja. An dieser Stelle, Dankeschön. Dankeschön, leider haben sie meinen Umzug nicht überlebt. Der hat noch umgezogen. Und dann hat es so eine große Schlucht, hat sich aufgetan, so mit Lava und dann musst du so ein paar Dauer reinschmeissen. Ja, ich musste Ballast abwerfen, ich saß im ICE, war mal wieder zu schwer. Du kannst eine DVD im Zweifelsfall aus der Hülle rausnehmen. Und dann? Ich habe mir die DVD angeguckt. Da freuen sich die Webcam-User, die diese tolle Reaktion von Stefan noch mitbekommen haben. Wie wär's denn noch mit einer Webcam eigentlich? Aber so eine richtige Oldschool-Cam, die alle 15 Minuten... Ein Bild macht! Aber genau in diesen 15 Minuten benehmen wir uns so, wie wir garantiert nicht aufnehmen. So einfach, dass wir wild irgendwie Handstand machen, alle 15 Minuten. Oder uns irgendwie die Klamotten tauschen. Wollen wir die Klamotten tauschen? Aber was hast du eigentlich für eine Grösse? L. L? Ja. Echt? Ich habe M. Ich habe eine kleinere Grösse als du. Ja, du bist breiter als ich. Ja, deswegen wundert es mich ja. L. Du bist breiter als ich. Ja, deswegen wundere ich mich, dass ich M habe und du L. Das Problem ist, glaube ich, die Länge. Guten Morgen, guten Morgen! Das Problem ist, glaube ich, die Länge. Also ich habe einen relativ langen Oberkörper und einen langen Penis. Und dadurch bekomme ich, natürlich muss ich längere T-Shirts tragen als du. Und L heisst ja nicht nur, dass es ein bisschen breiter ist, sondern auch ein bisschen länger ist. Das Problem ist bei mir, dass ich so einen langen Oberkörper habe, weil ich ja fast zwei Meter gross bin, dass ich eigentlich XL von der Länge brauche, aber L von der Breite. Und dadurch, da kommt man in so ein Wirrwarr und dann findet man nichts mehr anzuziehen. Die Breite ist ja wichtiger als die Länge, oder? Ja, nicht so richtig. Also sehe ich immer aus wie so ein Lörres, lau ich dann rum. Lörres. Lörres. Lörres? Ja. Ja. So. Gut, um zurück zu meinem Umzug zu kommen. Ich bin gerade umgezogen, von Berlin nach Köln. Wie lange ziehst du eigentlich? Wie lange braucht das eigentlich? Es war wirklich ein Leidensweg, es war eine Katastrophe. Du hast keine Möbel, sagst du andauernd, damit du, wenn du umziehst, keine Arbeit hast. Ja, aber diese Idee... Du bist der Mensch, der am längsten umgezogen ist. Ja. Ich habe noch niemand gesehen, der so lange umzieht. Hallo Marcel, hi. Können wir dir helfen? Ja. Wir können ja die Tür hier geben, wenn wir die Tür haben. Du willst echt die Tür jetzt ausbauen, ne? Wozu brauchst du eine Tür? Warum willst du die Tür aushebeln? Erstmal, herzlich willkommen, Marcel Lenz. Herzlich willkommen im Podcast-UFO, Marcel Magic von den Bustle Brothers. Das hat eben den Raum betreten. Du bist herzlich willkommen im Podcast-UFO, dem Podcast in Deutschland, wenn es um Sachen Comedy geht. Du hast unsere Aufnahme gestört, um eine Tür zu klauen. Was haben die Bastel... Nee, ist eine gute Tür. Kannst du da ja die Tür aufbauen. Welche willst du? Kannst du die hier zu der Tonkabine haben oder die? Man muss auch sagen, Marcel, hier sind sehr viele Türen in diesem Gebäude, aber ich habe schon oft gedacht, ich habe oft gedacht, diese Türen sind schon die schönsten hier. Also wenn ich irgendwo Türen klauen würde, würde ich auch hier klauen. Privat, habe ich richtig verstanden? Okay. Da hinten ist auch noch eine Tür, aber wo die die hinführt, weiss ich ja eigentlich. Nein, ja. Was ist denn da rechts davon? Ne, unscheinlich, woher die denn hinten, diese Tür da hinten?
Wollen wir die mal aufmachen jetzt?
Ist ein Notausgang bestimmt.
Aber das Gebäude hört doch da auf.
Es ist eine Truman Show, du lernst ab, dass ich irgendwo…
Schön ist die Daten, Marcel Magic mit, es geht immer irgendwo weiter.
Aber da ist eine Wand, ne, da geht's weiter.
Das interessiert mich jetzt wirklich mal.
Aber das ist kein Notausgang, oder?
Es steht zumindest nicht da. Ja, bedien dich, ne, greif zu, ne, greif zu. Hat nicht gepasst. Ach so, na gut. Dankeschön, dass du uns besucht hast. Na nöt. Ich komm wieder. Weiterhin. Mach's gut. Ciao, ciao.
Tschö, ciao.
Marcel Magic, meine Damen und Herren, Der Mann mit den Türen. Ein Mann. Wir müssen uns dringend. Macht haben, sie zu erfüllen. Wir müssen unser Ensemble erweitern. Die Podcast-Ufer-Familie muss, ich meine, wen haben wir denn? Muss wachsen, um Leute, die es schon in einer anderen Sendung in Ensemble geschafft haben. Ja, genau. Genau, wir sind die Ensemble-Tausch statt Frauentausch. Ich meine, wir haben Stefan Schwier, wir haben Miss-Podcast-Ufo 2015, Daria, wir haben Marcel Magic, wir haben den Tonmann vom letzten Mal, Cordula, Torben, Marcel, Benni, Becky! Nein, der Umzug war eine absolute Katastrophe, ich habe wahnsinnig viel Geld verloren, Kaution nicht bekommen, das ist einfach toll. Deine Ebay-Erfahrung, für die ich bieten sollte, war es sich lustigerweise vergessen, hat auch nicht so ganz geklappt. Ja, vor allem die Ebay. Das Problem ist, ich wollte Stühle verkaufen bei Ebay, allerdings wurden die erst verkauft, nachdem ich nicht mehr in der Wohnung war und die konnten nicht abgeholt werden. Und dann wollte ich die in den Keller stellen, damit der Käufer sie dort abholt, das fand der Vermieter aber nicht lustig. Und jetzt musste ich dem Käufer einfach auf E-Mail schreiben, lieber Käufer, ich habe leider die Kontrolle über die Stühle verloren und Sie können sie nicht länger abholen. Es tut mir leid. Alles, was Sie mir bis jetzt überwiesen haben. Wem gehören die denn jetzt? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Die sind besitzerlos. Die sind besitzlos, die schwimmen jetzt in unserer Art Mittelmeer oder so in so einem Limbus, in so einem Gesetzeslimbus sind die, die gehören niemandem. Limbo. Limbo, ja, tut mir leid. Tatsächlich, das ist echt ein Problem. Und ich muss echt sagen, ich kann nicht mehr auf diese zugreifen, obwohl ich sie verkauft habe, aber sie sind nicht länger, sie sind noch mein Eigentum, aber nicht mehr mein Besitz. Und das ist ein Problem. Nee, die sind noch dein Besitz, aber nicht mehr dein Eigentum. Nee, die sind mein Eigentum, aber nicht mein Besitz. Aber sie gehören dir noch. Ja gut, das ist jetzt kollektale Sprache, kolloquale Sprache, da möchte ich jetzt nicht weiter darauf eingehen, das interessiert mich nicht. Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil irgendwann also dir wurden quasi seine Stühle entfremdet, also die hat jemand geklaut, ohne dass du was dagegen unternehmen kannst, dass so jemand plötzlich dein Portemonnaie, dein ganzes Geld besitzt, ohne dass sie ihn klaut. Ich habe sie mir in gewisser Weise selbst geklaut. Ich habe sie selbst vor mir weggesperrt. Du hast wie eine Wand zwischen dir und den Schülern errichtet. Ich habe eine emotionale Wand aufgebaut zwischen den Schülern und mir und wir können uns jetzt nicht mehr sehen, einfach weil es zu schmerzhaft wäre. Man muss dazu sagen, das war Kapitalismus pur, du hast die geschenkt bekommen und wolltest die, weil die angeblich Designer-Schüler sind, wolltest die verkaufen für 5000 Euro. Ich meine und ich sollte da bieten noch und ich glaube, wenn ich dir da gebeten hätte, geboten, gebeten hätte und es hätte mich niemand überboten, war ja unsere mündliche Absprache, dass du die dann trotzdem nimmst, ich wette, du bist so ein Arschloch, du bist dann irgendwie auf die Ebay... Ich hätte meinen Heerscharen an Richtern auf dich losgelassen, um dich im Grundeboten zu klagen. Auf den Kaufvertrag hingewiesen, den du gelernt hast mal irgendwann in der Frank-Elzern-Schule, irgendwie Medienrecht oder so, und hättest dann gesagt, nee, da ist ein Kaufvertrag entstanden, du musst jetzt für 5000 Euro diese Schüler annehmen. Ja, es ist ein Problem. Ich meine, ich habe sie verkauft, sie gehören jetzt dem Käufer, aber ob sie dem Käufer zugänglich gemacht werden oder nicht, ist ja nicht mein Problem. Ob der an die kommt oder nicht, ist ja nicht mein Problem. Eigentlich, du hast wie gesagt eine Wand errichtet zwischen dir und den Stühlen, hast die aber während du die Mauer errichtet hast schon verkauft. Ja, das Eigentum wurde übertragen, aber nicht der Besitz, aber das ist ja nicht mein Problem. Aber das Geld gehörte schon, oder wie? Nee. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Das ist in der Tat ein Problem. Es ist eine absolute Katastrophe, von vorne bis hinten und dieser Umzug. Also für mich war da noch einigermaßen Wim. Du kannst ja einfach das Geld geben, sag, wo die stehen. Ja, aber der kommt da nicht ran. Ja, aber das ist doch sein Problem. Ja, aber der sagt, hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Du kannst mir die Sachen verkaufen, die du irgendwie in einem Tresor in der Schweiz eingeschlossen hast. Wow, dann kriegt Feedline-Punch, dann hat eine schlechte Bewertung bei Ebay. Ja, ich habe diesen, zum Glück, ich bin auf der sicheren Seite, aber ich habe diesen Account nur für diese eine Transaktion erstellt. Das heißt, wenn die mich jetzt im Grunde um Boden klagen, ich habe da auch eine falsche Adresse angegeben und alles, das heißt, irgendeine arme Sau in Pommern kommt da jetzt das SCK vorbei und nimmt denen sechs Stühle ab, einfach aus dem Haus zu machen. Naja, es war eine Katastrophe, aber für meinen Mitbewohner noch viel mehr, der hat sich da tapfert um alles gekümmert. Vielen Dank nochmal an der Stelle. Ich weiss, dass du den Podcast nur heimlich hörst. Deswegen, vielen Dank nochmal an der Stelle. Und es war tatsächlich lustig, weil wir hatten noch viel Kleidung übrig, die wir weggeworfen haben. Und dann haben wir den ganzen Tag gewartet, bis ein Carsharing-Auto in der Nähe war. Da kann man sich so einen Alarm einrichten. Wenn du diese App hast, sobald ein Auto in deiner Nähe abgestellt wird, kriegst du einen Alarm, jetzt ist ein Auto verfügbar, jetzt können sie mit dem Auto verfahren. Das ist schon so ein bisschen superheldenmäßig, ne? Das sind diese kleinen Mittel, die einen irgendwie an James Bond erinnern lassen und sich fühlen wie James Bond, aber uncooler sind, wesentlich uncooler sind in der Praxis. Ja, man hat halt James-Bond-Feeling plus warten. Man wartet halt einfach, bis man irgendwas cooles hat. James Bond muss in der Regel nicht warten. Das ist der Unterschied. Muss eher zwischen den Szenen, die man nicht sieht. Das kann gut sein. Aber schon geil, dass du kriegst einen Alarm, wenn ein gewisses Auto an deiner Nähe parkt oder so. Ja. Und dann im Endeffekt ist aber nur so ein dreckiges Smart oder sowas. Halt was so Uncooles, den du benutzen darfst für Geld. Auf jeden Fall haben wir dann den ganzen Tag gewartet, haben unsere ganzen Altkleider zusammengesammelt, weil wir wollten die natürlich abgeben, weil wir natürlich wollen, dass die Flüchtlinge in cooler, stylischer Kleidung von Sachsen gejagt werden.
Deswegen haben wir alle gesammelt und haben so lange gewartet, bis ein Auto verfügbar war.
Und dann war ein Auto verfügbar, wir hatten die ganzen Säcke in der Hand, sind runter in den Erdgeschoss gegangen,
wollten raus auf die Strasse und dann gehen auch raus auf die Strasse und stehen mitten in einem drei Kilometer langen Fahrradkolonne, irgendwie Berlin fährt Fahrrad mit Musik und Lichtern und allem möglichen drum und dran. Und hunderte Fahrradfahrer fahren uns vorbei, die gesamte Strasse ist blockiert, gesperrt, keine Chance, kein Durchkommen. Und wir stehen da und haben die ganze Hacke gewaltt und genau in dem Moment, in dem wir rausgegangen sind, unendlich viele Fahrräder mit Musik und LEDs und Lichtern und der uncoolste Umzug der Welt, Elefanten und Karawanen und so riesige. Und alle sind so glücklich und sind die einzigen, so wie verlorene Menschen dazwischen. Und so riesige asiatische Drachen wurden so vorbeigehen und wir nur mit unserer Einglager. Ich so, Leute, fickt euch einfach. Das war schon sehr schön. Das ist mir so ähnlich auch passiert. Ich musste nämlich mein Auto abholen, und dann bin ich mit einem Carsharing-Dienst zu meinem Auto wiedergefahren, wollte ich zumindest, in der Theorie, und genau in dem Moment war halt hier in Köln Karneval, und ich wusste nicht, dass es Dienstag war für mich, ist für mich kein Karneval mehr. Und dann habe ich mich ins Auto gesetzt, dann muss man ja seinen Code eingeben und sowas, und man bezahlt, fängt ja auch schon an zu bezahlen. Ich leh den Rückwärtsgang ein, hinter mir ist überall Blaulicht, da fanden die genau in dem Moment an, die Strasse zu sperren. Und es kommt dann dieser Karnevalsumzug, plötzlich die Strasse lang gefahren. Umzingelt. Und dann kam ich einfach nicht raus, du kommst dann einfach, dass kein Durchkommen in Köln. Und dann ist genau das Gleiche passiert. Ihr könnt jetzt mal zurückspulen und quasi alles, was Florentin gerade bei seinen Dingen gesagt hat, ist dann auch passiert, in Lustiger quasi. Und dann konnte ich dann irgendwann losfahren und mein Auto abholen. Das ist tatsächlich auch, ich glaube, so werde ich eines Tages bankrott gehen, indem ich irgendwo hin zu einem Bahnhof fahre, mein Zug fährt in fünf Minuten und ich schaff's nicht, dieses scheiss Car-to-go-Ding so abzuschalten, dass der Counter aufhört und ich einfach sag, fuck it, ich muss einfach mal hinzukriegen und lass den da für den Rest der Zeit, bis die nächste Gravitationsflut kommt und die Erde verschluckt, bis dahin countert der einfach Geld hoch und irgendwann bist du pleite, irgendwann sagen die, ja gut, ding, kriegst du eine Push-Nachricht, die sind jetzt pleite, tschüss, vielen Dank für die, für ihr Service. Für 100 Jahre Car to go. 160 Jahre guten Service. Wir machen jetzt auch mittlerweile keine Autos mehr, wir haben Geld, wir machen, wir machen, we weiss ich nicht, wir machen Finanzen oder sowas. Wir verkaufen jetzt so Pillen, die man schluckt und dann ist man in einem Ort, wo man sein will, so in der Zukunft, so ganz abgefahren. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es so, wir haben ja heute überlegt, was die Brille der Zukunft aussieht, also der Monitor der Zukunft. Ich sage, WLAN-Kontaktlinsen sind die Zukunft, dass man einfach irgendwo drauf drückt und dann sieht man einfach die Welt, wie sie wäre. Du hast gesagt, es geht wieder zurück in eine andere Richtung. Was war deine Idee? Ich habe jetzt neuerdings die Angst, dass man diese Wireless-Kopfhörer, dass du quasi so In-Ear-Kopfhörer hast. Das ist ein Fake, oder? Nein, In-Ear-Kopfhörer. Ach so ein Quatsch, was Bullshit, warum das Fake sein?
Echt, ich dachte, das wäre so The Onion-Artikel. Nein, das sind einfach Kopfhörer. So In-Ear-Kopfhörer ohne Kabel, die verlierst du einfach sofort. Ohne Kabel. Ja, willst du mich mal kurz ausreden lassen? Und ich finde, das Beruhigendste daran ist, dass du, wenn du die zu tief in den Ohr steckst, In-Ear-Kopfhörer, hast du dann doch ein Kabel, wo du die wieder rausziehen kannst. Dafür ist das Kabel auch da eigentlich. Ja, und ohne Wireless, also wenn die nicht Wireless sind, dann hast du einfach, ich habe Angst, dass meine grossen Ohren meine, meine Kopfhörer verschlucken und die einfach nicht mehr aufzufinden sind. Ich meine, du hast doch kein Kabel halt. Du hast ja schon vier, fünf Kopfhörer, da auch Headsets auch schon, hast du alle komplett in deinen Ohren verloren, die da einfach reingefallen sind. Das Bernsteinzimmer befindet sich in meinen Ohren. Richtig so wahrscheinlich, aber ich meine ganz im Ernst, diese Wireless-Dinge, die werden wahrscheinlich nie allzu günstig sein. Und der rempelt dich ein, ähm, ich sag's jetzt mal, ein Neger in der Fußgängerzone rempelt dich an, reisst dir das Ding aus dem Ohr und es ist einfach weg. Forget it, vergiss es weg. Aber wie will er es denn aus seinem Ohr reissen? Indem er dich anrempelt. Ich glaube, du bist kontinuierend dabei, so in deinen Ohren zu pulen, um da irgendwie, hab ich die Kopfhörer noch drin, du vergisst die auch einfach da drin. Ich glaube, irgendwann, du hast die ganze Zeit ein Wireless-Ohrhörer im Ohr, in der Zukunft, glaube ich. So wie in Hörer meinst du. Hat nie gesehen. Aber du kannst dann ja auch, du kannst dann irgendwie auf Durchzug stellen, du kannst irgendwie auf Durchzug stellen, dass du Leute hörst, in der Umgebung hörst, und wenn du Musik hören willst, dann machst du dich halt wieder an. Dass da quasi Mikros drin sind und du besser hörst. Die ganze Zeit schon. Das macht doch Sinn. Florentin. Ist alles okay, Stefan? Ja. Du bist hochrot angelaufen, deine Arten pulsieren, dein Hals sieht aus wie ein Milky Way. Was ist da los? Das ist die Zukunft. Die gehen uns was anderes an. Ja, aber ist ja gut, komm mal runter. Spann dich mal ein bisschen, mach mal eine Kerze an. Mach mal eine Duftkerze an. Ein Kumpel von mir kann nur arbeiten, wenn er immer eine Duftkerze anhat. Ich finde es so lächerlich. Und er arbeitet als Pointe? Duftkerzen machen. Duftkerzen-Tester wäre lustiger gewesen. Ja, auch nicht schlecht. Oder halt irgendwas, wo du auf gar keinen Fall eine Kerze anhast. Er kann nur arbeiten, wenn er Luftkerzen anmacht. Er ist ... Mein Freund kann nur arbeiten, wenn er in der Bank ist. Und er ist Eisverkäufer. So, ich weiß nicht, baut euren eigenen Gän. Da kommt er mit dem Eisver Eiserkrank um die Ecke. Nein, ich liefer doch nur Bausteine.
Ich liefer doch nur die Bausteine, aus denen sich die Leute ihre Gags herbauen können.
Das ist doch die Zukunft.
Du wirst in Zukunft kein Stand-Up-Comedia mehr hören, sondern eine App wird dir verschiedene Pointen vorschlagen und du suchst dir deine Lieblingspointe aus.
Make your own joke.
Da gab es ja immer so eine App, so eine bulgarische App, ne? Ich glaube die erste App, die Bulgur, Bulgur, Bulgur, Bulgur, Bulgur,ups für einen Witz, so Anfänge, was sagt der Arzt zum Bären, Bären. Was sagt die Lampe zum Arzt? Zum Patienten. Das ist keine Feedline, das ist einfach nur ein normaler Satz. Was sagt der Arzt zum Patienten? Kommen Sie in vier Tagen wieder. Ciao, mach's gut. Und wir sind Neo, Neo. So, und dann kannst du eben verschiedene Punchlines einreichen, also Pointen, ne, also sowas wie, was sagt der Arzt? Ich finde es so lächerlich, dass seine E-Mail-Adresse feedlinepunchline at gmail.de ist. Oh nein, du kannst ja nicht mal die E-Mail, ah toll, jetzt schuldig, hunderttausend E-Mails, postfach geflutet, oh da kommen schon die ersten, da kommen, oh schwierig, alter, schwirsen. Alter, seine Signatur ist halt 30 Megabyte groß. Du hast, wie oft hast du, wie alt warst du, als du diese E-Mail-Adresse angelegt hast? Zwölf? Nein, das ist okay. Das ist so, wie ich bei früher bei Knudels hies. Das ist halt meine Arbeitsadresse, ich bin nochmal ein Humorist. Ich beschäftige mich nochmal. Vor allem, in diesem Moment würde ich gerne sehen, wie das dir einfällt. Feedline, Punchline, wow, genauso funktionieren Gags, so ist Comedy, wow, guck mal, ob es das bei G-Mail noch nicht gab, weil irgendein Idiot das noch nicht eingetragen hat, weil es keinen Menschen gab, der so schlauer wie ich, nein, niemand war so uncool wie du und hast das gemacht. Genauso wie es heute in dem internen Abrechnungstool unserer Firma den Account florentin.will schon gab, jetzt bin ich florentin.will1, weil es Florentin.will schon gab. Du bist Florentin.will! Nein, ich habe eins bekommen. Florentin.will eins. Und da stelle ich mir zu Recht die Frage, wer zur Hölle hat Florentin.will? Das kann ja überhaupt nicht sein. Ja doch. Aber darüber wird auch alles abgerechnet, das ganze Geld, was hat jemand bekommen. Ich weiß, irgendjemand Schwiersinger? Nee, ich glaube dein böser Bruder, Borentin. Dein BB? Dein böser Bruder. Borentin Bill? Ich hasse Borentin Bill. Wenn ich dich finde, Borentin! Wenn ich ihn und Beffern finde, dann knallt es aber. Übrigens, unsere dummen Brüder. Falls ihr euch fragt, wie ihr uns mal live sehen könnt, eine Live-Podcast-Aufnahme, ich sag mal so, sagen wir es jetzt schon?
Madison Square Garden. Wir haben uns was Interessantes einfallen lassen. Unsere Plakate für unsere Live-Show hängen schon, allerdings spielen wir unter falschem Namen. Das heisst, es könnte sein, dass wenn ihr euch in der nächsten Zukunft in Kleinkunstorganisationen in Köln in eine mysteriöse Vorstellung begebt, kann es sein, dass wir dahinter stecken.
Dass ihr uns beiden seht live mit Knallerpointen, Megagags, fetzigen Bühneneinlagen, Hörspielen, die sich gewaschen haben.
Wir jonglieren mit Pointen, aber auch mit Bällen, drei Bällen, Drei Bällen. Zwei Bälle bis drei Bälle. Poahnten. Ein Ball, oder? Jeder ein Ball. Zusammen zwei. Die wir dann uns zuwerfen. Florentin wird auch viel, wird auch mit nacktem Oberkörper, so einen Ball, so einen grossen Gymnastikball hat er eine Nummer einstudiert. Ich bin aus Versehen in die Tür geplatzt, als du geübt hast. Ja, genau. Das war für, ja. Mega gut, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Wir haben ganz tolle, auch Karaoke-Nummern einstudiert. Und Badminton spielen wir, ne? Wir spielen eine Runde Federball. Ah, mein Gott, okay. Unser Bit, unser Bit. Das war jetzt wirklich, das war jetzt den Ball drei Meter in die Luft geworfen, weit ausgeholt und jetzt hit it! Wie uncool müssen sich eigentlich damals die Leute gefühlt haben, die Federball gespielt haben? Und wer war der einzig Coole, der gesagt hat, Leute, wir können nicht mehr Federball, das kann nicht mehr Federball heißen. Wir brauchen einen besseren Namen. Und was ist cool? Batman. Batman ist cool, also nennen wir uns eine Sportart. Badminton. Badminton. Das war der beste Direktor der Woche, präsentiert von Snickers. Snickers. Don't drink and drive. Don't drive. Don't drive, come on. Drink as much as you want, but don't drive. Das finde ich so lustig für eine Airline oder sowas. Don't drive. Oder drink and fly. Fly. Don't drink, drink and fly. You can drink, it's not necessarily a problem. Driving also, but ... Da dürfen Piloten mit Promille fliegen? Ah, gute Idee. Ich würde sagen, wir rufen einfach mal bei der Lufthansa an. Bäh Bam, bam, Episode 51.
Ich habe tatsächlich mal recherchiert, inwiefern Reiter im Strassenverkehr betrunken sein dürfen. In deinem anderen tollen Potlars-Projekt, was vor 20 Jahren mal modern war. Und tatsächlich dürfen Reiter im Strassenverkehr so betrunken sein, wie sie wollen, weil sie unter die gleiche Kategorie fallen wie Fussgänger. Und rein vom Strassengesetzverordnung gibt es ja auch keine Promillegrenze für Fussgänger oder für Inlineskater oder Leute, die auf Ratten reiten oder was auch immer, sondern die dürfen so viel trinken, wie sie wollen, weil sie keine motorisierten Verkehrsvernehmer haben. Ja, aber auf meinem Hoverboard. Auf deinem Swagway gilt natürlich ganz andere. Nee, aber ich gelte auch als Fussgänger darauf, tatsächlich. Weil die Dinger sind halt nicht grossartig motorisiert. Das ist auch der Gesetzestext. Nicht grossartig motorisiert. Das ist auch das Problem daran. Nicht nennenswert motorisiert. Ja, wann sieht man dich denn jetzt eigentlich mal auf den Strassenköln? Mensch, der Frühling steht in den Startlöchern, die Röcke werden kürzer, die Mädchen werden ... Und das Hoverboard wird rausgeholt. Und das Hoverboard wird rausgeholt. Es steht noch in meiner Garage. Und Stefan saust und flitzt durch die Kölner Innenstadt, die Röcke wehen ihm hinterher und er verbreitet Liebe, Lust und Leidenschaft in der Stadt der Liebe. Wann geht's los? Ich glaube, relativ bald. Ich glaube, ich habe auch keine Lust mehr, also ich habe keine Lust mehr auf Autos und keine Lust mehr zu gehen, weil mir ist was passiert mit meinem Auto. Ich wohne in einer Strasse, wo man einfach nicht parken kann. Das ist sehr uncool, die Parksituation in Köln ist generell bescheuert, aber da auch, weshalb ich quasi direkt hinter der Kurve geparkt habe. Und das gefiel dem Ordnungsamt nicht so. Ist das ein Euphemismus? Ich habe gestern hinter der Kurve geparkt.
Das steht auf meinem T-Shirt, das ist mein neues Startup.
Weshalb ich dann mein Auto im Halteverbot, wie es dann wieder das Ordnungsamt zu mir gesagt hat, im absoluten Halteverbot.
Aber das ist doch mega uncool. Es reicht auf Parkverbot.
Warum ist etwas noch absoluter verboten? Das stimmt, jedenfalls Das gibt es auch nur in Deutschland. Nein, habe ich Montag das hingestellt, dachte mir, du packst das nächsten Tag um, habe es wieder vergessen, wieder vergessen, wieder vergessen. Donnerstagmorgen um sechs Uhr steht das Ordnungsamt bei mir vor der Tür und klingelt, ich habe dir die Geschichte schon mal erzählt, aber ich will das für die Leute noch mal machen, weil es ist ein grandioses Bit. Und er hat geklingelt, aber dann hat es unerfällig weiter geklingelt, ich habe dir die Geschichte schon mal erzählt, aber ich will das für die Leute nochmal machen, weil es ist ein grandioses Bit.
Und er hat geklingelt, aber dann hat es unerfällig weiter geklingelt. Also er wusste offensichtlich, dass ich da war, was mega gruselig ist. Und dann habe ich aufgemacht und er hat einen Vortrag gehalten darüber, dass das Auto halt falsch steht, so ungefähr eine halbe Stunde lang, dass ich verantwortungsvoll parken soll. Und dann musste ich einfach nur mein Auto, weil es halt, es war, es war, es war, gut, er hat es formuliert absolutes haltenverbot aber es war in wirklichkeit nur zwei meter hinter dem normalen parkplatz ich musste drei meter nach vorne fahren wo gerade eine fahrlücke frei war und war fertig mit der sache einfach so kurz gas geben und manche anstehen anbremsen da haben sie es jetzt apropos standpauke ich musste mir auch eine scheiß standpauke anhören bei netto, weil du Depp nicht für mich gezahlt hast, als wir beide an der Kasse standen. Hast du echt Ärger bekommen dafür? Den ganzen Vormittag sage ich, ich erwarte einen sehr dringenden Anruf und wie es so dringende Anrufe so haben, kommen sie zum schlechtestmöglichen Zeitpunkt. Wir stehen gerade am Supermarkt an der Kasse, haben unsere Waren schön aufgereiht auf dem Laufband, der Anruf kommt, ich muss natürlich fliehen. Du musst nicht fliehen! Ziemlich in die Tiefkühlecke zurück, weil ich einfach ein bisschen Ruhe brauche. Und dann denkt man natürlich, okay, Stefan ist nicht nur Kollege, sondern ist auch mittlerweile so eine Art, ja, seelenverwandter Liebe des Lebens geworden auf irgendeine Art, würde dann einfach seinen winzigen, lächerlich winzigen Geldbeutel in die Hand nehmen, indem er trotzdem sein Vermögen irgendwie unterbringen kann. Zahlt einfach für mich mit und dann gebe ich ihm später das Geld. Was passiert? Nichts dergleichen. Er ist auch sofort gegangen, hat nicht auf mich gewartet, keine zwei Minuten, auf mich gewartet, dann stelle ich mich wieder an, muss trotzdem nochmal warten am Laufband, obwohl meine Waren schon vorne sind, die hat die Kassassiere neben sich gestellt. Sie hat, glaube ich, böse gemurmelt, das geht so aber nicht. Sie hat dann deine Waren alle neben sich gestellt, auf die Kasse gelegt. Und dann muss ich noch mal warten, ohne was zu haben, um dann zu sagen, ja, das ist meins. Und dann hat die erst mal ihre Arbeit eingestellt. So, Jungemann, jetzt sage ich ihnen einfach mal was. Hier, sie halten den gesamten Betrieb auf und und da müssen alle wegen Ihnen warten und ich habe auch besseres zu tun. Wirklich? Das ist dein Job, das ist genau dein Job zu kassieren. Du hast hinten noch eine Partie Rummikum am Laufen oder was da los? Burn, not.
Hast du nicht gesagt?
Nein.
Nicht mal annähern.
Und wäre auch nicht so cool gewesen, wenn.
Kleinlaut war einfach nur, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe gesagt, ja, ich habe einen sehr wichtigen Anruf bekommen.
Ja, ich habe ja auch eine sehr wichtige Arbeit zu verrichten.
Und ich mir dachte, naja, ich war schon bei Ikea, dann verrichtet deine Arbeit eine Maschine, sorry, ohne jetzt zu bitchy zu sein, aber. Aber die nehmen nur Karten, kein Kleingeld. dann musste ich dann das ganze Zeug bezahlen und die hat mir natürlich wieder lustigerweise irgendwelche Sachen dazu gelegt und dann habe ich wieder die XS-Kondome gekauft und alles in der Richtung.
Hahaha, grosser Spaß und nur so zum Thema, ne? Also hast du es auch verdient, sag ich mal. Standparken müssen wir auch manchmal sein, einfach damit man wieder in die gelenkten Bahnen des Lebens kommt. Ja, damit man auch merkt, dass man auf andere Leute wirkt und auch mal in einen anderen Dialekt einfach reinkommt. Einfach ein bisschen in einen anderen Dialekt reinkommt. Einfach ein bisschen reinkommt. Wir haben eine kleine Reise über die Weltkarte geplant.
Reise.
Urlaub steht an.
Wo geht's hin, Stefan?
Sylt.
Ja, wie jedes Jahr.
Wie jedes Jahr.
Westerland, Sylt, ordentlich.
Kannst du bitte für Westerland noch mal sehen, bitte?
Das hat mir so gut gefallen bei X-Faktor. Wie du einfach Westerland oder Westermann? Westermann. Janine Westermann? Oh, ich habe solche Sehnsucht. Hast du es echt angeguckt eigentlich? Klar, natürlich. Ich möchte hier aber jetzt nicht drüber reden. Vor allem, du hast es ja echt lange geschafft, es geheim zu halten mit deinem X-Faktor-Ding. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, damals... Ich habe es nicht geheim gehalten, ich habe es einfach nicht erwähnt. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, wie damals beim Neo Magazin, nicht beim Neo, zumindest Royal, sondern früher im Kleinstudio und alles, wo mehr oder weniger ...
Warst du dabei an dem Tag, wo es rauskam?
Wo mehr oder weniger Jan und ich die Sendung alleine geschrieben haben, kam eines Tages Jan wie ein strahlendes Kind in den Süßigkeitenladen, mit hochroten Augen und glühenden Wangen und brennenden Haaren und was auch immer, kam er an und hat nur Stefan angeschaut, hat weit gegrinst und hat seine Hände vor, seine Arme vor sich zu so einem X geformt, und hat mir Stefan-Faktor, X-Faktor, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, und du bist aus allen Wolken gefallen, ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, worum es geht, ich habe mich um meine Schokoladentasche gekümmert. Nee, das war irgendwie so die erste Woche, wo ich da angefangen habe. Ja. Und irgendwann hat Jan, weil er Leute stalkt einfach gerne, hat er dann das rausgefunden, weil es auch nicht so schwierig ist, rauszufinden, einfach mal Namen googeln. Das ist ja auf meiner Homepage steht ganz groß. Ich habe bei X-Faktor mitgemacht. Ich verstehe das nicht so gut im Internet. Ja. Aber er hat es relativ schnell rausgefunden und dann bin ich morgens ins Büro gekommen und es lief, es lief einfach mein Auftritt, wo ich bete, dass dieser Moment nie kommen würde und er ist gekommen. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, du hast bei dieser Fernsendung mitgemacht, du bist noch relativ weit gekommen, du musst ja wirklich auch für gewisse Momente gedacht haben, du wirst jetzt wirklich ein Star, oder? Ja, aber das Ding ist ja, da war ich ja sehr jung noch, also man ist ja sehr lange, sehr lange Zeit seines Lebens sehr jung und sehr dumm auch vor allem. Und man ist dann, wenn man mit so einer Band ist und euphorisiert ist und es lief ja auch ganz gut so in einer Heimatstadt, hat man diesen Gedanken, klar. Ich habe auch relativ lange gesagt, das kann was werden und es war auch lange Zeit meines Lebens ein Traum, Musiker zu werden. Du dachtest wirklich, ihr werdet der nächste Revolverherr? Ja, mindestens. Wenn nicht die neuen... Wann kam dann der Abstieg? Wann habt ihr dann gemerkt, das wird doch nichts? Weil mittlerweile ist die Band aufgelöst, ihr habt euch zurück zum Baumarkt begeben und verkauft jetzt weiter Mörtel. Also wann kam der Punkt, wo wo ihr gesagt habt, nee. Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Ich glaube, es war so ein bisschen danach
oder dabei, weil es war eine extrem
uncoole Veranstaltung.
Es ist natürlich mega uncool.
Ja, aber Showbusiness.
Ja, aber ich glaube, du musst mal in so einen Abgrund
schauen, des
Showbusiness, um zu verstehen,
dass du nur funktionierst,
wenn du das machst, worauf du dich hinterstehst und nicht nur das Motiv, Ruhm oder so im Vordergrund steht. Wir haben da halt Sachen machen müssen, wir haben besser dann singen müssen, sowas, einfach so wahnsinnig uncute Sachen, wo wir gesagt haben, wir klar machen, wir machen alles, was ihr uns sagt. Wenn die uns gesagt hätten, wir sollen Barbie-Girl singen, sofort. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt, du musst lernen, Dinge zu machen. Deswegen machen wir hier bei unserem kleinen Projekt. Ja, das habt ihr aber dann aber nicht getan. Du erzählst die Geschichte gerade so, als hätte sie ein Happy End, aber hat sie nicht. Nee, am Ende dieser Geschichte ist halt das Ende der Band. Die hat sich einfach aufgelöst. Ja, aber warum habt ihr dann nicht weiterhin das gemacht,, wo hinter ihr steht? Keine Ahnung. Ihr steht hinter Aufgeben, oder was? Ist das jetzt die Botschaft? Das ist die Botschaft. Jungs, was uns eigentlich im Innersten zusammenbietet, ist Aufgeben. Die Botschaft der Sache ist, dass du einfach das machen sollst, was dir Spaß macht. Du musst deine Träume verfolgen. Ja, ist doch gut. Du bist wieder hochrot. Was ist denn los? Du hast die dritte Duftkerze angemacht, komm mal runter. Oh, Blutdruck.
Was ist denn los bei dir, Stefan? Bist du nicht so ein Duftkerzen-Fan oder so ein Räucherstäbchen-Fan? Ich hasse jede Art von künstlichen Gerüchen. Ich hasse das. Perfum, perfum? Ich will nicht so viel über meine WG reden, weil ich nicht weiss, ob die Leute den Podcast hören oder nicht. Aber wirklich konstante Räucherstäbchen, und ich habe auch noch nie ein Räucherstäbchen gesehen. Ich weiss nur, dass es immer nach Räucherstäbchen riecht und es ist extrem unangenehm. Das finde ich echt sehr... Aber ich habe letztens, nur zu dem Thema, ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, das propagiert hat, dass man keine Ratschläge von erfolgreichen Menschen nehmen soll, weil erfolgreiche Menschen in der Regel die Ausnahme sind und die Strategie, die erfolgreiche Menschen gewählt haben, gar nicht notwendigerweise zum Erfolg führt, sondern es vielleicht auch einfach Zufall gewesen sein. Weil von tausend Menschen fehlen 999 Leute und einer ist erfolgreich, vielleicht durch Glück oder Zufall oder irgendwas und eigentlich sollte man eher mit den Leuten reden, die gefailt sind, aber denen hört niemand zu, weil deren Bücher sich nicht verkaufen, weil natürlich erfolgreiche Leute mehr Bücher verkaufen. Aber ich glaube, alle Leute, die gefailt sind, alle Leute, die erfolgreich sind, haben ja in ihren Gruppen Dinge gemeinsam. Und ich suche immer nach Leuten, also Leuten, die ich gut finde, nach Comedians, die ich gut finde und so, suche ich immer nach Dingen, die die gemeinsam haben. Also du glaubst, dass Steve Jobs und Stalin ähnliche Eigenschaften haben? Ja, ich glaube auch, dass Steve Jobs, nee, nicht zweifelig, ich glaube aber, dass Louis C.K. und Jerry Seinfeldt gleiche Eigenschaften haben. Also die in ihrem Business erfolgreich sind, Hitler und Stalin haben vielleicht gleiche Eigenschaften. Napoleon und Hitler haben gleiche Eigenschaften. Du willst mir sagen, dass Thomas Elvis Edison und unser Charlie ähnliche Eigenschaften haben, nur weil sie beide erfolgreich sind? Dass sie fast der gleiche Mensch sind, würde ich sagen, ja. Ist das wirklich deine Meinung? Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass Jan Böhmermann und Harald Schmidt sehr viele Sachen gemeinsam haben. Es ist ein Zufall, dass ich immer sehr ähnliche Menschen auseinandernehme, aber Leute, die in ihrem, in dem gleichen Business ähnlichen Erfolg haben, haben immer Dinge gemeinsam. Bin ich fest davon überzeugt. Also du meinst ernsthaft, dass Steffi Graf und Homer Simpson ähnliche Eigenschaften haben? Schön, dass du diesen Gag jetzt zweimal machst. Du glaubst wirklich, dass eine Lampe und eine Knoblauchwurst exakte Eigenschaften haben? Ja! Und wofür diese Geschichte jetzt hin? Du glaubst wirklich, dass der Buchstabe L und Montezuma irgendwas, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe nichts mehr. Es tut mir leid. Stefan, Schwier, es tut mir leid, wir haben nichts. Wann kommt Schwierig eigentlich mal als Gast? Boah, hör auf. Das ist meine Reaktion darauf. Wir machen gar keine Gäste mehr, oder? Wollen wir nicht mal lieber einen Gast machen? Doch, wir können gerne machen. Lächste Woche können wir gerne einen Gast haben. Wir können mal hier die Changeman einladen. Den kennst du doch ganz gut. Ja, können wir machen. Lustiger YouTuber, lustiger Vogel. Ja, aber dann sind wir wieder so awkward, dann sind wir wieder so Aufmerksamkeit und mag mich, mag mich. Sind wir nicht? Glaube ich schon. Bei welchem Gast waren wir denn so? Wir müssen einfach mal einen Typen von der Strasse holen, dessen Meinung uns egal ist. Ja genau, den wir nicht beeindrucken wollen. Ich habe folgende Idee. Ich habe die Idee, dass wir mal Ideen brainstormen sollten.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich habe die Idee, dass wir uns was ausdenken sollen. Ich habe die Idee, dass wir mal mehr Ideen brauchen eigentlich. Für Folgen, indem wir etwas ganz Besonderes machen, wo einzelne Folgen wie ein ganzes Podcast-Experiment sein sollen. Wir nennen dieses Zeitprojekt eine Unterrubrik des Podcasts Ufa, eine folgefüllende Rubrik. Everything is a Podcast mit Florentin Will und Stefan Rubrik's Club. Rubrik's Club. Club. Club. Club. Club. Und zwar, wir gucken zum Beispiel mal einen Tatort zusammen. Irgendwas, was wir hassen, was wir hassen, aber was Leute, was jetzt, ist ja bekannt, man guckt sich ja gerne einen Tatort an und lästert darüber bei Twitter und so, finde ich wahnsinnig nervig. Aber wir beide, als Leute, die das nicht gucken, warum machen wir nicht mal eine Folge, wo wir das kommentieren und so. Das ist ja auch das Clueless-Gamer-Prinzip von Conan O'Brien, der ... Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass Clueless-Gamer eine visuelle Ebene hat, wohingegen der Podcast nur eine Autos-Ebene hat. Dann stellen wir eine Webcam auf, die jede Sekunde ein Foto macht.
Scheiss Webcam, nur weil du Doktor Fehlkauf, die vor zwei Tagen eine sündhaft teure Webcam kauft hast.
Ich will die einmal benutzen, genau wie die GoPro.
Wo du jeder gesagt hast, Webcams sind einfach, kein Mensch kauft noch Webcams.
Genau wie die GoPro. Ich hätte so gerne eine GoPro, aber noch lieber hätte ich ein Leben, was eine GoPro nötig macht.
Ja, noch lieber als eine GoPro eigentlich.
Ich hätte noch lieber als eine GoPro, hätte ich gerne ein Leben, was eine GoPro nötig macht. Ja, stimmt. Das ist eigentlich die beste Werbung für GoPro. Ich will so weit sein mit meinem Leben, dass wenn ich mir eine GoPro kaufe, niemand fragt, warum hast du die jetzt gekauft. Ich will, dass Leute direkt sagen, aha, okay, du bist der Risky-Snowboarder-Guy. Das Einzige, was ich mehr will als eine Afrikola, ist ein Leben, in dem ich eine Afrikola zu Afrikola passe. Ja, ich wünsche dir manchmal, dass du einen anderen Style hättest, einen anderen Lifestyle, aber einfach einen anderen Kleidungsstil. Ich wäre gerne der Typ, der die ganze Zeit einen Anzug trägt, aber noch lieber hätte ich das Leben eines Typs, der immer anzuträgt. Mehr als einen Anzug. Ich wäre gerne jemand, der immer Anzüge trägt, aber heute gerade keinen Anzug anhat. Ja. Der wäre ich gern. Kann man den Regen eigentlich hören? Ich finde das sehr beruhigend. Ich finde es auch so toll. Das ist gerade der Regen. Oh, jetzt bin ich bauffrei. Auch Stefan. Oh Gott, ich habe ihn mir im Bauch gesehen, glaube ich. Kann ich mal anfassen? Aber nicht den Bauchnabel. Auf keinen Fall, ich würde den Nebenfassen. Das finde ich wahnsinnig eklig. Aber jetzt bin ich auch nicht mehr anfassen. Man darf nicht zu... Man muss es einfach manchmal machen. Würdest du dich ein bisschen als autistisch bezeichnen? Autistisch? Nein, nein. Das glaube ich wäre ungerecht. Ich berühre andere Menschen nicht gern. Und ichühre Menschen nicht einfach nicht oft auch, manchmal auch gar nicht aus dem Willen heraus, aber ich berühre Menschen sehr selten. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, ob das einfach, ich habe per se keine Abneigung dagegen. Ja, aber das ist ja normal, du berührst ja normalerweise nicht oft Menschen. Es gibt auch Leute, die einfach wahnsinnig oft andere umarmen oder so körperliche Menschen halt.
Da bin ich das Gegenteil von. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, ob das einfach so eine sehr leichte Ausprägung von Autismus oder sowas ist. Nee, ich würde das nicht mehr zu Autismus notwendigerweise ziehen. Ah, das ist nicht. Und beim Podcast-Doktor. Ich glaube, das ist Krebs eher. Ich würde aufpassen. Podcast-Doktor, was haben Sie für Probleme heute? Hallo. Also, schreibt mal für nächste Folge eure... Wir sind uns darüber bewusst, dass wir im Moment so eine gewisser Weise so einen Weg befinden, wo wir nicht genau wissen, wo der hinführt mit diesem Projekt. Und deswegen, um einen neuen Wind reinzubringen, würden wir euch bitten, ein bisschen geduldig zu sein. Wir machen demnächst geile experimentelle Folgen, neue, coole, krasse Projekte und … Nein, das ist wie eine Gravitationswelle, wir sind halt einfach gerade unten und das ist halt … Ich glaube nicht mein Physik-Podcast erwähnt so oft das Wort Gravitationswelle. Ist es der Ausdruck, den Wissenschaftler benutzen? Gravitationswelle, ja. Gravitationswave. Sagen die es auch oder sagen die dazu irgendwie Nexus 3 oder so? Ich glaube, sobald das Volk diesen Namen angenommen hat, denken die sich wieder an anderen Namen aus, um sich abzugrenzen einfach. Die nennen es dann einfach die Einstein-Welle oder sowas oder die Cobra 3. Der Druck eines Physikers ist wahnsinnig gross, in seinem Leben was zu erreichen, was andere noch nicht vorhin erreicht haben. Ich glaube, der Druck eines Comedians ist geringer als der eines Physikers, weil der halt sein Leben hat, um irgendwie so eine grosse Formel aufzustellen oder was auch immer. Ja, vor allem jeder Physiker, der heute jetzt in die Uni geht, muss ja erstmal alles lernen, was bis jetzt überhaupt schon erforscht wurde und kann dann, wenn er alles gelernt hat, vielleicht noch mal oben was selber draufsetzen. Die Physiker in einhundert Jahren müssen … Da reicht ein Leben gar nicht mehr aus, um überhaupt alles zu lernen, was sie haben. Deswegen werden Menschen immer älter. Müssen sie zwangsläufig werden, oder sind länger leistungsfähig, weil sonst könnten sie ja gar nicht mehr auf dem alten Wissen aufmachen, ausser sie lernen schneller, ausser die didaktischen Fähigkeiten der Lehrer werden auch immer besser, so dass sie immer mehr Wissen in kürzerer Zeit vermitteln können. Glaubst du, dass irgendwann wir so eine Art Datenchip implantiert bekommen, mit dem Wissen unserer Schulzeit zum Beispiel? Also dass wir nicht mehr in die Schule gehen müssen, sondern das Leben quasi auf so einer Diskette irgendwie reingespeist bekommen oder sowas? Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir sowas im Körper haben werden. Ich glaube, wir werden vielleicht Technik haben, die sehr weit entwickelt ist, dass wir dann irgendwie so einen Stöpsel im Ohr haben oder so, der uns alles einflüstert, der vielleicht schon auf Gedankenwellen reagieren kann und schon antizipiert, was wir gleich wissen wollen. Wow, nachts irgendwie, dass man sich so eine Brille aufsetzt oder so einen Knopf im Ohr hat, wo einfach irgendwer reingesprochen hat, irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, Tom Hanks oder so, Sachen wie Blau und Gelb ergibt die Farbe Grün. Oder, warte mal, nee, sorry, ich blätter ganz normal. Die armen Menschen können sich da nur ganz schlechte Audiobücher leisten, von irgendwelchen Leuten, die Dinge aussprechen. Das ist nur ein Kaffeefleck. Und jetzt hier fehlt eine Seite, aber, nee. Licht sind elektromagnetische Wellen, die in bestimmten Frequenzen vom Auge wahrgenommen werden. Andi, kannst du mir noch mal einen Kaffee bringen? Können wir kurz Pause machen. Noch mal einen Kaffee bringen, bitte, das wäre sehr nett von dir. Boah, Alter, ey. Und dann wachst du morgens auf und hast halt das Wissen davon in deinem Kopf und das Gefühl, dass Tom Hanks ein wahnsinnig müder Mensch ist. Oder dass du ihn sehr gut persönlich kennst. Nee, aber du hast ja dein Studium abgeschlossen jetzt eigentlich, ne? Nee. Wie? Nee, es ist mein Praxissemester gerade. Ich befinde mich jetzt gerade, stehe ich im Praxissemester. Das meinen Sie doch nicht ernst, ein Podcast als Praxissemester? Nee, es muss schon eine eingetragene Firma sein. Du bist beim Zirkus jetzt,, ein halbes Jahr. Ich bin jetzt ein halbes Jahr beim Imphantasialand. Ja. Als Drache engagiert worden. Ja. Kopf. Also es gibt, Jeff ist mein Freund, der ist hinten quasi das Hinterteil des Drachens. Aha. Aber ich bin der Kopf. Finde ich auch gut eigentlich. Ich bin auch eher so ein Kopftyp. Ja. Bisschen verkopfter Job eigentlich. Genau. Und ein halbes Jahr bin ich jetzt da im Phantasialand. Eigentlich ein ganz cooler Job. Ja. Und danach habe ich mein Bachelor-Schreibsemester, wo ich quasi keinen Kurs habe, sondern nur meine Bachelorarbeit schreibe. Aber musst du die Bachelorarbeit auch in dem Kopf schreiben? Oder geht es dann... Da schreibe ich dann meine Bachelorarbeit drin und dann gebe ich die ab und dann bin ich fertig mit dem Studium. Und auch nur, wenn ich die letzte Medien-Ethik-Klausur bestanden habe, was ich nicht glaube.
Denn man kann sie mir jetzt, wow, war die Spiel. Regeln Sie nicht deine Stärke. Wupp, wupp, und scheiss. Die Professorin hat am Anfang gesagt, was drankommt und was nicht, das stimmt sehr genau. Und die erste Frage in der Klausur war, und sie meinte irgendwie, ja Aristoteles ist nur wichtig, was er über das Menschenbild gesagt hat und sowas. Die erste Frage war, was bedeutet der Satz von Aristoteles, irgendwie ein halber Kreis ist wichtiger als der ganze oder so irgendein Crap, was Aristoteles über einen Kreis gesagt hat, wo man direkt dachte, fuck you, was, wie unkoll ist das denn, dann sag einfach gar nichts, dann sag einfach, lernt, was wir besprochen haben mal irgendwann. Aber dann sag doch nicht einfach, dann grenzt es doch nicht ein, wenn es eh falsch ist.
Aber die Frage ist, du bist ja ein sehr rebellischer Typ, ne? Letztens hast du ja gesagt, Gesetze sind da, um unter Umständen manchmal in gewissen Situationen, wenn man gerade sich nicht so ganz so etwas hilft und oder man sich der Gesetzeslage nicht hundertprozentig bewusst ist, sodass man im Endeffekt nicht weiss. Und oder man damit das System sogar verbessert.
Oder verbessert oder man nicht genau die Gesetze kennt und dadurch so vielleicht durch so eine Tett-a-Tett mit Gesetzen für Hüttern vielleicht eventuell einen Vorteil langen könnte. Glaubst du, Rebellen kennen sich besser mit Gesetzen aus oder schlechter? Weil um sie zu brechen, müssen sie ja ein Verständnis von Gesetzen und Regeln haben und Systemen. Oder der Gesetzestreue kennt sich besser mit Gesetzen aus, weil ihnen folgt. Mhm. Wer hat das grössere Gesetzverständnis? Der Rebell oder der gesetzestreue Mensch? Oder Bienen? Schreibt eure Antwort auf eine Postkarte und in die Kommentare. Schreibt die Antwort auf eine Postkarte, macht ein Foto von der Postkarte und schreibt sie als Kommentar. Das geht gar nicht, man kann keine Bilder posten. Dann postet sie auf Facebook unter der aktuellen Foto und postet auch mal ein Bild von euch! Findet auch hier, dass Florentin gerade viel zu viel gesprochen hat, dann schreibt einfach unter das Video Team Frank Elster beim Chat-Duell einfach auch ein lustiges Kommentar, weil da gehören sie hin. Wie der sich immer in den Vordergrund drängt und dass er sich nicht hinter seiner Theke aufhalten kann und dass er Spaß hat, wie er will gewinnen in der Quizshow, unverschämt. Man kann sich nicht so viele Accounts bei YouTube machen, wie ich dachte. Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Ich habe mir sehr viele Accounts anlegen müssen, um diese ganzen Hasskommentare dazu zu schreiben. Ja, ich sag die schon. Aber tatsächlich haben die mich gehatet in den YouTube-Kommentaren von diesem Video und dann hat irgendjemand mich verteidigt und hat gesagt, hey, ich finde Florentin eigentlich ganz lustig. Und dann hat jemand drunter geschrieben, ist das Florentins Fake-Account? Und dann dachte ich mir, was mache ich jetzt? Schreibe ich jetzt mit meinem echten Account drunter? Nein, stimmt gar nicht. Was es aber mega offensichtlich machen würde, das ist doch. Obwohl das eigentlich der lustigere Move ist, Leuten, die eigentlich gar nicht meine Fake-Accounts sind, mal aber so zu tun, als wäre es meine Fake-Accounts. Dass selbst die paranoid werden und denken so, was, wie jetzt?
Existiere ich überhaupt? Was will ich?
Also einfach so, nein, überhaupt nicht, es ist mein Fake-Kommentar, in genau dem gleichen Wortlaut, in der gleichen Schriftart und so.
Oder du zwingst ihn dazu, etwas zu sagen, was nur du wissen kannst, was so eine Sicherheitsfrage ihn stellen lässt.
Ja, das finde ich auch gut. Welche Frage könnte man, Stell mir mal eine Frage, die nur ich beantworten kann. Ja. Welcher Tag ist heute? Wie lang ist dein Bein? 57 cm. Ja, habe ich nicht gewusst. Deswegen war ich. Also, war ich interessant. Gut, das war's, bis zum nächsten Mal. Gibt's eigentlich so Freundschaftsbücher, so Dittel-Freundschaftsbücher, mit sehr creepy Fragen, so irgendwie, wann hast du zum ersten Mal. Wie viele Hamster hast du erwirkt? Ja genau, so sehr spezifisch, die sehr spezifisch werden. Wie viel Zeit hast du schon an der Ecke Parkstrasse, Schroesingerstrasse verbracht, zwischen 5 und 30? Machst du eigentlich jeden Abend diese ausrufenden Yoga-Sessions bei offenem Fenster? Genau. So sehr spezifische Fragen, die viel zu sehr in eine Richtung... Aber auch gedruckt in dem Poesiealbum wirklich sind. Genau, genau gedruckt drinstehen. Ist Stefan wirklich dein richtiger Name? Wow! Moment mal kurz. Ja, das finde ich lustig.
Mach das mal irgendwie. Mach da mal ein Bild raus, so ein GIF oder so. Rute, mach da mal was raus. Oder malt ihr doch mal einen Rute-Comic, dass sich die Medien so ein bisschen vermischen. Oder macht mal ihr einen Podcast, eine Podcast-Antwort oder sowas. Hey, was ist los, Stefan? Hast du noch was auf dem Herzen? Du hast so ein bisschen ...
Nee, ich habe so ein ...
In meinem Gagdokument habe ich noch Dinge.
Ich wollte kurz mal gucken, ob ich noch was habe, was ich noch raushauen wollte.
Das Doofe ist, dass wir, wenn wir eine Woche lang nichts aufnehmen, dass wir uns immer in der Zeit die Dinge schon erzählen, die wir quasi erlebt haben und nicht mehr im Podcast erzählen. Also wir haben letzte Woche eine Woche Pause gemacht, weil du irgendwie umziehen musstest oder sowas. Und in der Zeit habe ich halt schon alle Dinge erzählt, die ich jetzt in der Podcast-Folge monierweise erzählt hätte. Wie zum Beispiel,
dass ich zum ersten Mal allein im Kino war.
Das ganze Kino war leer, es war 23 Uhr abends, wo ich dachte,
da ist niemand wirklich im Kino.
Aber es waren
erwachsene Männer
und eine Frau, so eine Gruppe,
so eine coole Clique, so Ende 40,
die nochmal dachten, wir hauen nochmal ordentlich am Putzabend
und gehen abends ins Kino, haben sich betrunken,
dachten, es wäre wahnsinnig lustig, ins Kino zu gehen. Und das war der erste Abend, wo ich dachte, Karma existiert wirklich, weil das ganze Kino war leer, nur die haben sich genau hinter mich gesetzt und waren die ganze Zeit kontinuierlich laut am Lachen und am Reden. Also es wäre völlig scheißegal, aber die wussten gar nicht mehr, wo sie sind. Die haben einfach laut geredet und ich habe mich umgeguckt die ganze Zeit, aber nur dann haben die angefangen zu lachen über mein Gesicht, weiß ich nicht worüber. Mega unangenehm. Wenn dein Gesicht lustiger ist als der Film, dann hast du was noch falsch. Es war so unangenehm und die werden so betrunken und irgendwann hat einfach der Mann gesagt, genau hinter mir hat der Mann angefangen zu würgen, also offensiv zu würgen, da hat ich mir auch so schlecht als der Film jetzt nicht. War hast du dich ja nicht umgesetzt. Ich kann mich einfach aufstehen und gehen und mich anders hinsetzen. Ja, hast recht. Machen wir dann aber nicht. Aber was wäre die Ultima Ratio? Was kann man machen? Pass auf. Weil du kannst ja nicht verhaften lassen. Ich dachte mir, komm, es existiert sowas wie Karma, dem wird es was Schlechtes widerfahren. In dem Moment fängt er mal hinter mir an zu würgen, hat dann gesagt, ich muss jetzt hier raus, ich muss jetzt hier raus, ich muss dringend nach Hause und es sind alle gegangen.
Und da dachte ich mir, das Beste ist einfach abzuwarten und nichts zu machen, ab und zu ein bisschen lächeln, nach hinten zu gucken, um zu zeigen, hallo, Sie sind ja nicht alleine unbedingt und in dem Moment sind die einfach gegangen. Ja, das ist deine Antwort, einfach Karma die Arbeit übernehmen zu lassen? Ne, meine Antwort ist einfach, sich zurücklehnen und nichts zu machen, nicht aktiv zu werden. Pegida, lass die laufen. Die stolpern irgendwann. Irgendwann fangen die an zu würgen und zu gehen. Gehen sie nach Hause, ja. Sorry, ich muss nach Hause. Ich fand, du hattest heute einen sehr guten Gag mit dem Friseur, aber auf den warte ich tatsächlich, hat mich schon gefreut, dass du den Hau noch rausholst. Ja, aber das ist auch so ein Ding, das habe ich dir eben schon erzählt und ich habe eigentlich keine Lust, das normal zu erzählen. Aber wirklich, bau den in Stand-up, der ist wirklich gut. Ich fand den wirklich gut. Du kannst uns die ganze Folge jetzt noch machen, einfach über den Gag reden, wie gut der eigentlich ist, aber ihn nie erzählen. Aber ändere vielleicht den Friseur zu einem Zahnarzt, weil ich glaube, Zahnarzt gerade mit dem Lächeln ist Zahnarzt vielleicht ein bisschen passender, aber Friseur ist auch gut. Ja. Aber überleg dir da nochmal was. Obwohl das natürlich ein bisschen nah dran an, haha, die Zahnärzte stellen dir immer eine
Frage und du kannst gar nicht antworten, weil du vier Finger im Mund hast oder so. Den klassischen
Luke Mockridge-Gag. Der klassische LM-Gag, der Lemmy, wie ich ihn nenne. Luke Mockridge habe ich
ein Video von ihm gesehen, was zuvor auf meine Facebook-Teilmine gespült wurde. Und zwar hat
Er ist ein, das wir Auf seiner Comedy-Show. Ja, wie man halt ironisch Wonderwall singen kann mit 60.000 hier diesen Glühstäben. Studentinnen. Diese Stäben, die die haben, die leuchten. Leuchtstäbe. Brennstäbe. Glühkerzen, Brennkerzen, Wunderkerzen, Wunderkerzen. Die haben alle die in der Luft gehalten und dann hat der Wonderwall ironisch gesungen. Das war echt, da dachte ich mir, wow, also das kann nicht besser werden. Ah, riesige Katastrophe. Es passiert auch immer, dass wenn man bei Geburtstagstorten die Kerzen zu nah aneinander stellt, dass dann aus bei Oma irgendwie 93 und 93 Kerzen, dass dann, wenn du 93 Kerzen zu nah aneinander stellst, dass sie dann irgendwann zu einer grossen Flamme werden, zu einer grossen Kerze. Und so habe ich mir das auch gedacht, dass wenn 60.000... Dann bist du zu alt. Ich glaube, wenn du den Kuchen vor lauter Kerzen nicht mehr siehst und eine grosse Stichflamme entsteht. Und du darin verbrennst, das ist so ein bisschen Selektion, dass wenn du zu viele Kerzen hast, dass sie automatisch explodieren. Da habe ich mich auch gefragt, das habe ich mich immer mal gefragt, wenn Leute klatschen, nachdem jemand die Kerzen ausgepustet hat, in welchem Jahrhundert war das eigentlich eine Leistung? Wann hat sich das durchgesetzt, dass man klatscht, wenn Leute Geburtstagskerzen auspusten? Wow, ich puste sehr oft Kerzen aus und da klatscht niemand,
außer wenn ich Geburtstag habe. Dann ist plötzlich eine Leistung oder was. Ich übe das ganze Jahr nur für diesen einen Tag.
Aber wann ist das entstanden? Irgendwie hat irgendwer mal gesagt, wenn man Geburtstag hat, kann man nicht gut pusten.
Wann ist das random entstanden? Kann sein. Und so dachte ich mir auch bei 60.000 Studentinnen, die gleichzeitig eine Wunderkerze hochhalten und dann einfach zu einer riesigen großen Stickflamme werden. Und längst das Arena ist weg. Einfach mal alle kommen mit abbrennen. Köln ist weg. Und Luke Morgnisch geht wahrscheinlich in den Flammen seiner Fans auf, was wahrscheinlich für ihn in Ordnung wäre. Er starb bei seiner Lieblingsbeschäftigung. Als er Wonderwall spielte. Ironisch. Die Folge war auch ironisch, oder? Ja, war auch ironisch. Ich fange nicht
an, nebenbei Mail zu beantworten. Wir haben tatsächlich gerade eine Mail in den Kommentar
bekommen, ich weiss nicht, ob du das auch gerade gesehen hast, und zwar schreibt Fanboy, schreibt,
ihr könntet zwischendurch wenigstens eine Folge mit weissem Rauschen hochladen. Extra für Fanboy, jetzt zum Abschluss nochmal weisses Rauschen. Ja, weil das suchst du dann raus, okay? Es gibt in der Tat ein Rauschen, was glücklich machen soll. Es gibt zwei Formen von Rauschen, ich meine dunkles und weisses oder so, schwarzes und weisses. Nee, Rauchen meinst du? Sind wir über der Zeit schon? Kön, können wir jetzt schon abbrechen theoretisch? Ich würde jetzt sagen, beenden statt abbrechen, aber ja, wir können aufhören.
Also bis vor, bis schon abbrechen. Bis Minute dreissig heißt es abbrechen, ab Minute dreissig heißt es,
können wir wirklich abmoderieren jetzt. Also wir können abmoderieren, ohne dass es illegal wirkt.
Ich glaube, wir können rausgehen.
Und wir sind Neo, Neo, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle, alle Ich glaube, wir können rausgehen. Und wir sind Neo, Neo,
dann würde ich sagen,
die ist ja immer in unserer Partition nach dem
All the single ladies, all the single ladies,
all the single ladies, all the single ladies,
dann bitte ich mal.